no once we're live mr david gentlemen we
are live we're officially live
episode number 79 21 away from 100 folks
if you haven't yet subscribed to the
channel
please do so once we reach 100 000 subs
we may be going to three times a week so
give us that thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel today we
have tom ellsworth with us and gerard
michaels is uh back and we got a lot of
things to talk about
the uh the video got a lot of messages
about uh you know trump and obama
getting together we'll have some
uh uh updates on that but we've got a
lot of other things to talk about tom
why don't you give everybody an update
on the message you got from american
airlines on gas
fuel shortage what's that all about yeah
so i think everybody that has a frequent
flyer number um
whether you're on delta american
airlines you know delta american
airlines apparently sent it out this
week
saying notices saying hey there's some
fuel shortages please bear with us we
may uh cancel a few flights here and
there
uh instead of four flights a day maybe
three and expect
a uh the end at the end of summer and uh
back to school things tightening up in
terms of
prices going up and please bear with us
i've
that is not a customer service message
it seemed like a warning
that the airlines are preparing for a
rough fall that's what it sounded like
airlines are looking for a rough fall
fuel shortages yesterday i'm talking to
a guy that runs a
uh uh in fair prices they say he he runs
a uh
what do you call it he builds home so
what do you call when you were general
contractor the general contractor yeah
but you know how you come and see the
model homes and then he builds the model
home for you with it oh he's a developer
yeah he's a developer so i said so how's
business he calls me says you know what
i'm so pissed off right now so what are
you pissed off about he says my main guy
my main gc that i've been using for the
last 10 years
every time we do a deal together the
property is up the house is up within
six months today
i'm talking to him he says he can't do
it for me for 12 months
i said so what are you doing so i got an
option number two in an option he says i
called everybody
in town right everybody says 12 months
there's nothing i can do about it i said
you have no leverage today
yeah i said so what's your game plan he
said i'm calling the guy the gc to tell
him typically whatever you were charging
me i'm willing to charge
i'm willing to pay 20 more for you to do
it
in six months because his guy is saying
there is shortage so he's calling the
clients
to say look if you want this thing to be
built up i can do it but if you want it
in six months
you got to pay that 20 so it's a very
interesting time right now
it's not just shortage of fuel there's
shortage in a lot of things today
oh absolutely as a matter of fact uh php
your other business is doing fantastic
and what are you so what are you doing
you're expanding your headquarters
and you're doing the uh and you're doing
the remodel and you know that i'm
i see that in dallas right in the middle
of it and the the contractor said the
same thing and it's
it's situational concrete and drywall
apparently are near impossible to get
in uh in dallas concrete and drywall not
near impossible erase the audio a little
bit still a little low for me folks is
your is my audio low just tell me if it
is or not i'm curious but go ahead
yeah and what he's saying is situational
and he was saying the things that need
shipping like there are some lights and
some other things for the ceiling and
we're not ordering custom lights
you know but uh he says look i can't get
things in i'm trying to get things
shipped he said there's a trucker
shortage which was the
similar thing that i saw last night
network news talking about that the
trucking shortages transporting fuel
because it's fuel remember it takes up a
lot of space it's heavy you have a lot
of rail a lot of tank
he said they can't get it so he said
shipping concrete drywall in dallas and
it's affecting the completion date
remember this is supposed to be done
mid-summer now it's not going to be done
yeah yeah the new so i'll see what's
going to happen well somebody that's
been in construction for people out
there that don't know
the way that it affects prices is
normally the the the valuation that we
all give is two parts parts one part
labor
so somebody's going to be more expensive
on labor because there's not enough
of it that they're going to do something
12 months out and parts are already more
expensive
so you're you're doubling down on the
labor cost actually in that
in that regard because we don't in in
construction we don't charge
by time i'm not a twenty dollar an hour
employee or whatever right
it's if the parts of this are ten
thousand dollars then i charge five
thousand dollars it's a fifteen thousand
dollar project that's how you come up
with your valuations two parts parts one
part labor
so if the parts are already more
expensive the labor's already charging
more
so if the parts cost me 12 grand i'm not
still charging five i'm charging six now
so that fifteen thousand dollar project
is an eighteen thousand dollar project
now if you're kicking another twenty
percent on top of that that fifteen
thousand dollar project
just became what seventeen five eighteen
thousand just off the bat
right there so that's three thousand
dollars right now
off of the same exact project in that
hypothetical and by the way so so folks
i don't know if you saw this one i would
janet yellen i mean i you saw what janet
yellen said kai do you have the
powell story i think i want to read both
of these stories simultaneously because
yellen what was yellen's prior job what
was her job before
uh her uh current job she was with
chairman the fed right so here's here's
what happened with yellen and then we'll
go into
what powell said if you want to go to
page seven page seven janet yellen
she also got a million dollars from
melvin capital by the way
to to make sure that uh gme didn't uh
bankrupt them but that's a whole
different thing so let me read this
story uh
uh words consulting teams leave me alone
page seven or six let me see
janet yellen says page seven but i don't
see it on page seven where is
janet yellen story kai
oh let me see here i don't see it on
seven
six right here okay but it says seven on
the paper just so you know that kind of
is it on page nine with a bad haircut
there we go okay six so janet yellen
to take extraordinary measures to
prevent u.s from debt default this is a
newsweek story
treasury sector secretary janet allen
says she will take
extraordinary measure to prevent the u.s
from her default on the national debt
unless congress asks to suspend or
increase the debt limit she warned
congressional leaders in a letter friday
in a letter to house
speaker nancy pelosi yell and put
lawmakers on notice that the treasury
department will end the
end at the end of july suspend the sale
of bonds the avenue by which the u.s
finances
its debt obligations for two years the
debt limits have been suspended
currently the debt bound by the limits
is 20.4 trillion dollars
the debt default has never been
permitted by the government white house
secretary jim sackey
told reporters friday saying the
possibility would be a catastrophic
event yelen said
a default would cause irreplaceable harm
to the us economy and the livelihoods
of all americans tom what's your
thoughts on this this is a cut and paste
headline that every three years shows up
and then they just raise the ceiling
and they sit there and they debate it
and then nobody wants to be the first
person to the floor of the congress
remember congress is the purse senate is
the approval
and nobody wants to be the one that
raises it you remember this
remember so i i think this is this is
right on time every three years they
have to act responsible
and they're telling you they're freaking
out average
americans saying default oh my gosh
what's going on here and then they're
just going to take a stroke of the pen
and they're going to raise the ceiling
we could go back and google this three
years ago and you'll find similar
headlines
and nobody wants then mitch mcconnell
didn't want to be the guy that
authorized it because he didn't want to
get pinned you raised the debt
you raised the debt because there's
always an election coming nixon took us
off the gold standard tommy had one
famous quote and it's we're all kenzians
now
we're all kenzians now dude what what
it's a hal holbrook quote from the
original wall street movie
i haven't seen things this bad since
that bastard nixon took us off the gold
standard there you go
do you remember that we're all kenzians
man so dude th this is
this is p like the the fiat currency
that that we're working off of right now
it's
so it's so disappointing man because
what did we just get for the stemly list
to bail out what how much
money does it cost to run our country
right now
they they can't run it on five trillion
they can't run it on eight trillion
but it's okay let's raise the debt limit
because if we give them 10 trillion
dollars of our money guys
they'll get it they'll nail it at 10
trillion i'm sure they'll be responsible
on this next batch
of stimulus qe 55 whatever it is
quantitative easing forever
they took all the money they shut us
down they took all our money and they
gave it to all their buddies
and now they're saying i don't know what
happened to all the money guys we're
gonna default
you gotta give us some more of your
money otherwise ah it's gotta be
catastrophic
man oh man i gotta tell you man we are
we are entering the the
the the sherwood forest phase of the
american economy we are just getting
ripped off by the people that are
supposed to be can you pull out the
powell story pull up the palestine
because these two go together so here's
powell
fetch powell feels heat from all sides
as inflation spikes both the fed and
biden administration have paid
rapid price increasing or being stoked
by temporary factors
what was the comment that he made this
is politico using the word spikes
powell warned lawmakers on wednesday
that inflation is likely to remain high
for
months before cooling down in the wake
of
hotter than expected price increases in
may and june but he reassured them
that the central bank was on top of it
okay guys i just want to make sure don't
worry about it he's on top of it
everything's going to be all right he's
reassuring the rest of us
so how bad right now we got 5.4
what number you think it will peak at i
i believe that we have a 10 to 15
inflation year in progress a 10 to 15
percent so
damn straight because they'll announce
10 or 15 no hell node it's just like
labor statistics they're going to be
manipulated
but i believe it's there you can't find
me anybody with common sense i
and you know what i don't care what
level of education you have
don't underestimate the man on the
street the average american educated or
not you know like college educated
whatever it is
they understand it they see what's going
on rents are going up because they're
tied to housing prices housing is going
up because it's tied
new housing they're just going to walk
around the supermarket
hang on yeah now let's go to the let's
go to the two necessary parts of the
supermarket right
let's go back to uh produce and let's go
back to
dairy so look at a gallon of milk and go
look at what's happening there uh
i'm shocked that you know
the news media and politicians and that
was politico that actually used the word
spike with inflation in the headline you
know how careful they've been on
headlines all year
they're starting to see it i think the
average person on the street
good grief american airlines and delta
send you emails saying hey there's a
fuel shortage shortage means prices go
up
and we paid a little bit more on the php
office renovation
these are just examples that we can talk
about around the table you go down to
starbucks and you conduct a survey with
the man on the street
you know what you're gonna have you're
gonna have people to tell you oh when i
just went to buy a car i can't even get
a car oh the lease was gonna be this
this is gonna be this
the average american is seeing it and
feeling it even though the headlines
have been trying to make sure
that americans don't get too freaked out
about it i think we're at 10 to 15
right effing now pat we have a lot of
like younger viewers
that are just getting started right so
what how would you explain inflation to
them how would you explain inflation to
the 18 19 20 year old
kid how would you explain it to them in
a way that they can tangibly
you know understand what's going on
without it coming off as some like
esoteric scary uh you know economic term
all right like there's a guy he's just
starting his career wants to be an
entrepreneur he's getting in the sales
did you talk about high school what age
kids should talk about
let's say the bottom age of the of the
valuetainment demographic the people
that are just getting into
starting to dip their toes in in
politics economics they're starting to
think about these things they're
starting to
to to be curious about the world at
large how would you explain inflation we
talk about it a lot but i don't really
think people
understand the gravity of the situation
how would you explain inflation to them
i i you know it's very interesting my
youngest brooker who every now and then
is on the uh
case studies thank you very much so
she's going into fifth grade
and i gave her a simple example like
this i said you know that soda machine
that i hate that's at your school
and now it's got 20 ounce sodas in there
all that caffeine and sugar
yeah what if you walk by it one day it's
a dollar the next day you walk by it's a
dollar twenty-five
right what is your allowance per week
she says well ten dollars but i have to
do this and this and this and this
i said that's right and what if i just
tell you that i'm only going to keep
paying you ten dollars
yet you walk by the soda machine now
it's 7.25
brooke that's inflation what i pay you
per week
now take a look at everything think of
it as gas we put in the car
all these things that's inflation broke
those prices go up and yet
you still make 10 a week your little
allowance but she has to do things i
don't just hand it out
and now we're entering you know so
there's the basics a lot of libertarians
are starting to throw the term
death spiral out where we're entering a
situation where the federal government
is advocating for higher taxes
wages are stagnant and you have
inflation and they're pumping dollars in
that the american consumer immediately
spends
and sends straight to the bottom line
people say how's the stock market up the
economies was so bad
because we pumped a bunch of money into
the consumer's pocket they spend it on
things
and it lands on the bottom line and it's
supporting the stock market there's
actually somebody here that lived
through inflation right vanessa you you
were in
in venezuela right yeah it's not fun
runaway inflation what what was it like
what year were you there
i left on 2012.
so that was before travis was still
alive
but my mom was like i feel like she says
that somehow
she's like you're out of here and then a
few years later he went
downhill yeah so it was already
happening in the inflation that's when
it started and then it got really bad
yeah and then they had to turn off
electricity sometimes and things turn
off water
and then chavez got sick and then he
died right yes correct so this was at
the beginning of it your mom saw it
coming and got you out
yes this was you know so people don't
understand the price of bread was just
to use american terms it was like one
dollar
and the next day was two dollars a week
later it was ten dollars and then it was
a thousand dollars
a month later like a bread could be like
a million dollars now
for a loaf of bread wait what'd you say
a bread a loaf of bread
compared to dollars currency can be a
million dollars
a loaf of bread is a million dollars in
venezuela
do you know the conversion u.s one
dollar venezuela it goes
up so fast that i stopped
yeah that that that's that's wow that's
society
that's the end of society why would
anybody ever play by society's rules at
that point
then it just becomes survival of the
fittest you go back to you know feudal
warlords
the biggest the biggest thing work where
i'm happy about is the following let me
tell you what i'm happy about
and not happy about but i'm glad it's
predictable
anything that's unpredictable is quite
scary
things that are predictable to me
you actually pulled it up i don't even
know what number though dear god
oh my god 398 billion dollars to buy
yeah that's why 400 billion dollars is
one dollar
yeah both of ours 400 million bolivar
to one and any of us in the united
states do you remember when the peso was
crazy
you would you would take ten dollars in
the united states you would go down to
tijuana
and you were given like 200 000 pesos
remember
and gum was like 50 000. but let me say
this let me let me say this part the
part that gives me confidence the
following
if i do something wrong there should be
repercussions to it
so the best thing is that inflation is
happening
for the american people to realize the
next time you say yes to just printing
money for the hell of it
know that this is the consequences you
just have to know if you say yes to this
this is what's coming so maybe a
temporary you know
relief or whatever maybe but you have to
face this year right now with the
inflation that uh
and by the way you know who inflation
benefits who who wins from inflation
the poor the middle class or the rich
who wins from inflation wealthy the rich
rich always win and by the way who
causes inflation the wealthy
who causes inflammation government the
government responding to the policies
that the rich want yeah so it's it's the
actually they don't always want it but
the government causes inflation so you
said the rich the wealthy uh
cause inflation or the government causes
inflation i don't think that there's a
distinction between the two anymore
so you think the rich are the government
i don't think i think that
i call it the ivy league cabal it's
there's a very very clear
there's a very to me a very clear group
of particularly ivy league educated
people who they all come from the same
schools
they all go into the same groups and
they
want a global government and they want a
global economy
i don't think anything that's happening
right now has caught any of these people
by surprise
the i agree there's two things that you
have to understand from my time in
politics
there you have two people two sides they
come together you have the greedy
and the crazy the crazy and the greedy
that's it you have the people who are
ideologues who will do anything they
will give up their time on the weekends
to stand in front of a post office
to hand out literature they're
proselytizing they don't have a
spreadsheet
this is their religion this is their
religion okay
and then you have the greedy and they're
just ambitious and this is just a way
for them to get what they want and they
understand
anybody who's in the private sector are
trying to compete they're suckers why
don't i just make the rules for me
right i always trust the greedy more
than i trust the crazy
because you can predict it i can predict
them and i i
trust they want what's best for them
this is when people talked about donald
trump was going to burn things to the
ground and i didn't vote for trump the
first time
i didn't think he would because all this
guy cares about is his legacy
this is a guy who puts his name in
40-foot gold letters
on every building that he owns you think
he was going to let things go down
absolutely you think he was going to let
himself go down in history that way
no way i trusted his ambition i trusted
his greed
okay what i don't trust is the crazy and
i think that's what we have now
people who want to see the thing burn to
the ground because
something new and noble will come from
its ashes
we need to hollow this system out
because it's not working for everybody
it's only working for 95
of us so we got to burn it to the ground
yeah go through 10 years of horror
and then something new and noble will
emerge that's where i think we're at and
that's what bothers me
you shot a whole new mass mandate that
masks are coming back
yeah which one so first of all doj is
now
uh uh allowing uh the government to
mandate
vaccine if they chose to so that's one
that we saw on tuesday
two now cdc is saying that indoor uh not
only whether you're vaccinated or not
vaccinated you're required to wear masks
they're going back at it again
i got a box because they found out
yesterday that even vaccinated or
unvaccinated people might be carrying
viral load
you know and they were talking about the
the name i got master's just in case you
wanted mass time i got them here for you
and i got babies
and you've got hang on pat you have n95
you have medical masks so
i would have more more respect for this
mandate if it was medical mass you have
to have an n95
are you wait are you telling me this
isn't a hazmat suit wait
i thought that this was a magic force
field that protected me from everything
they're so funny what happened you're so
funny but what do you think about the
mask being back what do you think about
mastery
um yesterday there were several
municipalities and states oh nevada
nevada came and said hey
where masks uh you know what is it 5 p.m
on
the 30th coming up the end of this week
they even said because remember between
now on the 30th apparently you're safe
so we're going to wait till the 30th as
of the 30th we have mass come back
i i so i've never i i'm there with
with cdc and everybody that says if it
there is no dispute
that if it's not an n95 the
effectiveness of the mask
is really if it's not an n95 if it's not
an n95 that the viruses come through set
there
so number one i number one i think
they're that the mass
thing is is kind of a fear-mongering
because it
it really doesn't make a huge difference
it's a beautiful way for the globalists
to literally
muzzle the disobedience anonymize
everything and i
and i am well if you want to move from
max to vaccine real quick for a second
so yesterday my mom has some teeth
surgery
she's 84 years old she had a terrible
problem with the tooth they got to put
on a post they had to knock her out to
do it
so i go there drop her off she's an hour
two hours anesthesia she comes out of it
a little punch drunk
i took care of her for five hours and
her doctor says to me
it says um it says oh you're vaccinated
okay babs you're vaccinated great
and we got to talking and he said we
have well the uh j and j booster shot
remember the same
j and he says why is it he says well it
turns out that the uh
he says you can go look this up tom j
was like
one third of the potency of moderna
which is why people were complaining
about moderna the people who got the
moderna sometimes said
you had a higher percent of those people
going oh my gosh over three days i
thought maybe i got covered
from this vaccination and then they
would get their second moderna and get
the heavy feeling again well apparently
listen to this doctor the j j shot was
one third
of the uh potency of the moderna shot
so one third of the you know that all
the dynamic that goes in there to cause
your system to respond make antibodies
which is why g j needs to have a booster
and by the way
then you go into the seasonal effect
what do we do every august united states
oh
are you telling me the science on this
isn't settled tom are you telling me
this is
not an experimental thing no and by the
way we get flu shots every year
we get flu shots every year because
remember you know winter is upside down
in australia so by the time we get
around to august september well it could
be a pretty good flu season here in the
united states
turn the mic off right keep going and so
i
so that's how i feel i feel that this
there is so much that's unresolved here
so now you're going to tell me that i
can go to work
as long as i'm vaccinated but what if i
did get the j and j
and i'm really not as resistant and now
i can propagate it
that is not as that is not the same as
you getting the moderna
if you are less likely to propagate it
so being vaccinated
is an unequal statement by scientific
definition right
because i could be more contaminant than
you
based on which vaccination i got with
barely a year of research
and the doctor also said that you got to
take the vaccine every year it's kind of
like a flu shot take your flu shot
correct
so but but but here's here here's the
part here's the part that
uh the doj is saying that the government
can
mandate you know government employees
taking vaccines when i was in the army i
had no choice here's how they broke it
down to me you are government property
you work for the government
if the government wants to give you
shots they can give it to you and
even in 1997 they said look
they're going to give us all this stuff
that they tested for some military folks
we're like test dummies right jacob and
you would go
through this row i was talking to about
it last night
you would walk and there'd be two guys
like 11 people
five and five it was five and six i'm
gonna be 11 shots and it's air guns you
go
right right near your shoulder one one
one one one one you get 11 shots right
here and if you moved
it cuts you i mean it's like legit stuff
if if you move
so they can go and do non-stop shots and
it's
not a big deal when they're doing it
right and soldiers are kind of coming
through
they tell you there could be potential
side effects you there could be
long-term ramifications to it we don't
know what's going to happen to you but
you have to do it this is what's your
government property and you could die
next year attacking somebody so we're
not really worried about i wish you knew
what it was that let you function on
three hours of sleep i would take that
shot tomorrow that's
whatever they gave you
you just inspired 18 people to take the
vaccine to be able to go on three hours
of sleep
50-year time release speed hey if you
choose to work for the government if you
just
work work for the government hey there's
a part of it that's
you're a government property military
now some of the other government
employees that can fight it
what becomes interesting is yesterday
i'm watching cuomo chris cuomo
right and i'm sitting there watching him
i'm watching don and i'm seeing what
they're saying the green eyed monster
yeah i'm watching
chris and and we're going back and forth
i think you were there sitting we're
watching cuomo
yeah and uh you see person after person
after person
you saw barclay yesterday i don't know
if you saw what barkley said yesterday
about the vaccine barbara he said
uh uh uh what was the words he used he
he said what what did he say he said it
would be terrible he said if you haven't
taken the vac here the only people who
are not vaccinated the only people who
are not vaccinated are just [ __ ]
okay
that's what barkley said and then uh uh
you you saw pelosi going uh at mccarthy
talking about that
he's an absolute moment yeah she get in
the car right then you saw
uh gerardo uh geraldo or geraldo
on um i think it was the five where he
got up there and he says
if you don't take the vaccine you're an
absolute idiot if you don't take it why
aren't you taking it etc etc right
so now the next thing is let's let's
figure
out ways to divide people even more
before it was
you know a trump against you know
everybody else then before that it was
you know whoever you know january 6
insurrection which is all over tv right
now and then it's now
the vax against the unvacs and if you're
on vacs right now you're absolute
you know a menace to society it's
another way of trying to divide so
here's what my idea was yesterday i
presented my idea right kai
if you haven't seen it i don't know if
you've seen it or not kyle let's play
the clip
play the clip of what what i think would
be one way to help unify america and i
want to get your thoughts
and i also want to kind of give you an
idea what's been happening since then on
what kind of messages i started getting
with this kaif you can raise the volume
see where the volume is at
your message here too okay and then uh
go ahead and press play
but i'm deeply concerned with how
divided america is today and i think
there are only two people that can help
us unify america with one of them being
former president
barack obama and the other being yes
donald j trump and this is why i'm
putting five million dollars of my own
money
two and a half million dollars to
president obama two and a half million
dollars
to president trump to agree to do a long
form interview to discuss
ideas with only one thing in mind to
help unify
america having said that president obama
president trump let me address why i
think you ought to consider doing this
number one i think if we were to look at
america as a left wing
and a right wing i think the voice of
the left wing today is still president
obama and the voice of the right wing
today
is still president donald j trump but
when i think about the two of you i
think about two people who both
love america they have different ideas
but i think both of you
love america and i also see today
whenever i see a husband and wife that
are about to go through a divorce we see
signs of a divorce you see it six months
before 12 months before eight months
before
and you try to do whatever you can to
save that marriage but you kind of see
it's coming i think the world if they're
watching us
china iran russia is seeing a great
divorce could potentially happen with
the united states of america
and what can we do to save that marriage
obviously they would love to see us get
a divorce
but i think amen both of you admire
abraham lincoln once said the following
we are not enemies but friends we must
not be enemies
though passion may have strained it must
not break our bonds of affection
the mystic chords of memory will swell
when again touched
as surely they will be by the better
angels of our nature
i don't know if you'll agree with us or
not but i think the world thinks the two
of you are enemies and it doesn't make
any sense to have two presidents of the
greatest nation in the world
to be enemies what do you think would
happen if the two of you sat down
together
how would china iran or russia react to
that why does this matter to me see i
have four kids i just had my last kid
two weeks ago brooklyn ivy bed david and
i'm in the hospital looking at this baby
saying to myself
your daddy's dreams became a reality
because of this great country called
america with the flag behind me
but are your dreams going to become a
reality is this the same thing as it was
42 years ago 22 years ago i don't know
i'm gonna do my part i can't run for
office
but i'm gonna do whatever i can to unite
this great nation here so if you're
watching this
and if you agree to this i would love to
schedule the time and folks if you're
watching this and you want to see this
become a reality
share with everybody you know
i don't bother if you're watching this
i'm curious i'm watching the commentary
right now put a thumbs up if you'd like
to see this not whether you believe this
could happen
or not put a thumbs up if you'd like to
see this put a thumbs down
if you don't want to see this at all you
don't think it would do anything to help
reunite america gerard your reaction to
something like this if
it were to happen well first of all you
know you're welcome um
for uh the usage of my backyard there uh
no no beautiful choice you got there i
gotta tell you yeah beautiful home i
appreciate that
uh it's fine you know we we had the
cabana open for you
uh what do i think i think a a
discussion
not a debate uh an actual discussion
between these two folks uh on
on how we got to where we are and really
just focused on solutions of how we can
get
forward past this would be the greatest
thing to ever happen
in the history of american media i
cannot think of any time in my life
that two opposing factions sat down
and one took accountability for how we
got here because they both have a hand
in where the nation is right now
and then propose solutions going forward
you know
it's it's like getting two gang leaders
to the table the only thing that i could
kind of think of
was back in the day when i was young and
this is something a lot of people aren't
going to know about but it's part of my
irish heritage so we were aware of it
it's when clinton got the crown and the
ira to sit down together
and say look we got to stop we got to
stop blowing things up in belfast we got
to stop putting bombs in
in garbage cans in london right and that
has the whole ulster question
that had a a massive effect on the world
the eu
doesn't exist today without first that
that domino
of falling right so i think any time
there can be a daytime any time that
there can be communication between
two warring factions and make no mistake
about it the left and the right the
politicians in dc are
at war with one another make no mistake
about it
anytime that they can sit down and talk
and walk us all brat back from the brink
i think it's it's a necessary thing and
and are you really going to put five
million enough in this five million
bucks
for real is that that's not a gimmick
like 100
100 5 million bucks why would i say it
and not do it
dude that's awesome i hope i you know
yeah i i hope that they
i hope that they are man enough to do it
i hope that they are man enough to sit
down in their beliefs
and say this isn't about me this is
about us
and i hope i i hope it gets to them and
i hope that they see this and i hope
that their first reaction is like no way
and then i hope the people out there
and the valuetainers because you guys
hit up my dms and i know how persuasive
you can be
i hope you guys are blasting these
people i hope you're blasting their
camps i hope you find out who their
campaign managers are
because that's the truth if you want to
talk to these people you find out who
their campaign managers are
and you blast them with this and you you
the squeaky wheel gets there
who wants to see this happen who doesn't
want to see this happen that's the real
question i mean if you
think about like if you look at the
messaging and when this went out
yesterday i got a lot of calls from
people saying you know i shared this
with my group and everybody said you
know i had people saying why the hell
would
obama ever sit across a you know con man
like trump
and then there were people that said why
the hell would trump ever sit down with
somebody that says conniving
i mean it's like on both sides there are
some people that cannot get that
division
out of their minds to see this thing
take place but who do you not think
wants to see this happen and who do you
think wants to see this happen
i i look we're a government
as as you pointed out of identity
right and identity politics is the tool
of the left at the moment
to run on identity whereas the tool of
the right is still
running on ideas but ideas and then
identity is a close second
it creates a division so i don't think
pelosi wants to see this
pelosi's been spending they would have
to change
so pelosi doesn't want to see it because
they've spent so much time
generating so much momentum taking
advantage of all the unrest and all the
its various forms of the last 14 months
i don't think she wants to see this
because she would have to she would have
to concede certain points
so i don't think the left is going to
want to see this because
they would have to concede points and
they are the volatile side of the
argument
in terms of the incendiary part of it
whereas the right
tends to be the reactive part of it
they're usually reacting to the
incendiary
there's sins on both sides but i don't
think that the hard
left leadership wants to see it the uh
i don't know if i could even say his
name it it rhymes with uh
uh c singh uh ting would not like to see
this happen
he's he spent a lot more than five
million dollars to rip this country in
half and he's always got it
they've almost got it we we what
let me let me let me ask a question a
different way i got a guy yesterday i'm
trying to get a seat
he messaged me right now his phone
number i'm texting him uh
uh to get them on here but here's here
look at it from a different standpoint
this text video look at it from a
different standpoint here's a question
say it happens okay let's just say it
happens let's say we have the meeting
set up
and trump and obama are sitting right
across from one another
long form interviews sit down okay now
when i first announced this and we were
talking about remember when this was
this was uh
a few days before fourth of july when i
said i want to do this they're like pat
this is crazy you know this is
and we went i don't know until what time
it was midnight when we were processing
this together we've known about doing
this for how long now since one o'clock
in the morning one o'clock in the
morning this is a week before fourth of
july so go whatever today's date is
go to then that's about five weeks and
it happened off the cuff we were at the
kitchen
uh uh you know just having a
conversation i said i'd like to see this
take place right
but say this takes place and they're
sitting there together
my only reason why i think this
first thing you said you think this
could take place i said i think this
could take place
but i said there's only one person that
wouldn't want this to happen
and you said who wouldn't want this
thing to happen i said oprah winfrey
why wouldn't you want why wouldn't
because the first thing is going to be
if oprah's camp gets a hold of this
they send it to her she goes to abc and
says let me do this interview why would
i let somebody else do the interview
i think a long form interview in a
format like this to sit down and have
the right questions to be asked to hear
both of them go at it if that were to
take place
how do you think the world's going to
react what do you think positively it's
going to do to america if it actually
did take place
and how will it do anything any negative
impact on who so how will the world
react
what positive impact will it have and
what negative impact will it have
yeah to me first of all it'd be
cathartic like
i'm done with debates these these canned
questions and the sound bites i'm done
it's not
it's not an actual debate a sit-down
conversation where they actually could
call each other
you know see each other as as equals see
each other not you know not necessarily
as adversaries but two wings of the same
bird
look we talk about it on this podcast
all the time i just want to live in the
same reality with people i disagree i
don't need to agree with everybody i
just want to live in the same reality
that they live in
there's people when i was up in new york
i'm like dude we don't live in the same
reality
when there's people looking at bill de
blasio the mayor of new york
telling us the voluntary phase of this
vaccination is over
and people being like okay good that's a
good thing and i'm like what we're not
living in the same reality
that the government just said that
they're gonna come to your door kick the
door down
and shove something that you don't want
inside your body i mean what
i mean what what's the difference
between consent and what's the
difference between
you know and not it's consent what's the
difference i'm not going to use the r
word and get this thing
but i'm saying that's it the difference
between sex and something else is just
consent
that's all it is so now these guys are
gonna take your body
they think they own you the government
does not own me
the government does not stay on this
topic tell me about this topic though
who tom who who how would the world
react to it
if this were to actually happen well
this happened in my lifetime and
you would have been very very very very
very small but
uh one of the gentleman's probably one
of the nicest
and most uh integris people ever to be
in the white house
but he was a very ineffective leader in
president which is jimmy carter
jimmy carter got the camp david
peace accord pulled off and the world
watched in
shock as he took menachembegan and anwar
sadat i believe it was
to camp david and got them to agree on
things and agree to peace
and there are many people including me
i'm not part of politics but
everything i've read it cost anwar sadat
his life
he was assassinated later but they
a world watched in absolute
shock and awe in a good way as the two
sides came together and if kai can find
the pictures of a camp david peace
accord
going back there before it was right
before 1980
um it's happened before in our lifetime
where two
avowed enemies got together and the
world
was shocked and inspired there they are
look at that picture they were they were
actually laughing
there was relationship look at there you
can't fake that that was not
modern-day faked images pat those images
there
are men who now have some semblance of a
relationship
as a result and it started as a sit down
brokered by jimmy
carter who is in the middle of breaking
the us economy another story
brokered by jimmy carter to get these
two folks together so what do you think
would happen
i think you'd have this kite you're not
on a
camp david stage and nobel peace prize
and all this stuff
but i think that if you truly got it
together
there would be a percent of people that
look at it like this
and would be really inspired by pat
look at the far left the first picture
look at him there with jimmy carter hand
on his heart lower
lower left okay before now look at
that yeah which two guys
don't look like they want to be there
and then look at the other picture
i believe we can make progress on this
and i think we've seen it
right here in our lifetime when you get
sides together
and you can have some sort of a dialogue
and move it forward something
something can happen there'll be parts
of this country that don't want it to
happen
gee that that that want to undermine it
all
but i i think it would be a moment that
i think would be
strong what what would you hope to get
out of it i mean what would you hope to
get out of it what would you ask them
how could you get them off of their
talking points
how could you they're so entrenched in
their talking points how would they just
not take the money
and use it to further messaging that's
already out there they're all over the
place
somebody asked me a question they said
you know why don't you give the two and
a half million dollars to charity i said
i don't
the money can go anywhere that wants to
go to if they want to give it a charity
or if they want to keep it matter of
fact
uh i'm i'm gonna keep raising money to
see if this money needs to get higher
for us to be able to make this happen
whether it's
somebody said why don't you announce
that anybody that matches your 5 million
they're actually
in the room when the interview takes
place so if somebody wants to match 5
million
what if we get 10 people that put up 5
million now we got 50 million dollars
now we're raising some money what if
people are donating a thousand dollars
two thousand dollars five thousand
dollars
to be able to make this thing happen and
then eventually we get the attention i
don't know if we're announcing a hundred
million dollars
you might be a millionaire you might be
able to afford 100 for 100 million
dollars yeah if
if we get to 50 million dollars a pop do
i get a painting
if we get to a point where we're raising
that kind of money to get the attention
of it you want to give it to charity
what do you want to give it to president
obama you want to give it to illinois to
help some kids out great
hey president trump you want to help
some of the guys do what you want do
what you want to do with it
yours charity whatever it may be here's
here's what i do believe here's what i
do believe
i believe this is going to happen i
fully believe this is going to happen
the only thing with this
on whether it's going to happen or not
is whether people want to see an oprah
winfrey do the interview or if people
want to see
a podcast do the interview that's the
real difference
i'm going to go raise the money i'm
willing to have that money being brought
up
i've sat in a lot of different
conversations in my life where
people who didn't want to talk to each
other and i've always seen
99 of issues that you have
will be resolved when you face off with
each other because at the end of the day
even the person you can't stand the most
if you spend a few hours with them and
you talk you'll eventually realize
we have a lot more in common than we
actually think in common
right if you actually think about how
many things barack obama and donald
trump
differ in how many thing you think it is
how many things is it
say stuff that they fully disagree with
is it a thousand things
is it a hundred things is it fifty
things it's probably nuanced within
those things but what i'm saying to you
is how many thinks you think it is
is it is it family you think neither one
of them value family
you think neither one of them uh value
uh the ability to communicate a message
you think neither one of them value
the ability to work hard you think obama
became a two-term president by now
working his tail off on the campaign
you think trump became who he is today
but not wanting to go out there and work
his tail off to make money
what what what values do they do there's
there's hundreds they're on the same
page with
the the idea becomes let's identify what
the two of you guys agree with
what are some areas that you disagree
with and how do we get here
and what are both of you willing to
commit to you chose to go into public
service nobody encouraged you to go into
it
you chose to go into public service what
do we need to do to bring this thing
together because at this point of the
game
it's no longer about you know whether
america is going to be the greatest
country in the world forever that's not
what it's looking like right now you got
countries like china that are catching
up
you got countries from many different
places that are not intimidated
of america like they once used to be i
think if they sit down together
and they go from one state where we're
talking and asking some questions about
how we got here
and then it gets to a point where i just
pause and i say can you guys just talk
the two of you and we're going to watch
what questions do you have for each
other
i think there's got to be an approach
where they talk to one another and then
we ask the questions
and see where that goes but i can tell
you by the time it's over with
if it's done properly the world's gonna
look at it and say
this is not good because if it becomes
them against the world this is not a
good thing if it becomes them against
the world could that happen could it not
happen i don't
know but all i'm when a lot of people
say it's a terrible idea one guy said
it's a narcissistic idea you have no
idea how this is a narcissistic idea
to come up with this you know when you
think about an idea i got people that
said i don't know why nobody else
thought about this before i don't know
why nobody else has announced this
before
the reality of it is if we can unite
is america worth uniting the answer is
what
hell yes if it's not then you give me
your alternative
if somebody says terrible idea what's
your idea
what do you suggest doing somebody said
we should put all the media heads
on a yacht send them out there and you
know sink the ship you got somebody on
twitter that said this
people are making some of the most you
know random comments about how to go out
there
to help you reunite america in a
situation like this
if you don't think this is a great idea
i'd like to see other people propose a
right to you here's other the odd
example harry truman said it right the
you've been to the uh the capitol they
have those enormous enormous statues at
statuary hall the capital well
apparently once upon a time those were
all
right above the senate building and they
noticed cracks in the ceiling and they
told harry truman says yeah we can't do
something at the senate today because
they're up there moving all the statues
around because they're worried
that all these statues are going to come
through the ceiling and he said
don't move the statues someday those
statues may do a great service to the
american people
the kind of put them all on a yacht and
sink it right
um i you know i i i'm with pat
right you know this is the classic
example of america
is a family in a car pat where do you
want to go for dinner i don't know where
do you want to go i don't care
well if somebody does make a decision we
all go hungry and i think it's
if you don't like this idea and you
don't want to do it this way how do we
want to do it
because we we we got to come together
and we we have to get a unifying force
and you know what's really funny
the further and further and further that
you usually push
citizens apart you usually have an
anti-government
fracture you usually will have a
fracture on both sides
the farther and farther you push people
apart and it
the the most dangerous thing for a
politician
is one thing it says a
suddenly unified populous
and it's dangerous for power i'm not
talking about death when you overthrow
the government or coups
it's dangerous for shifts of power
because you get things like the great
depression you get things that that
happen
and the most dangerous thing for
politics status quo
is a unified populous spurred
by a crisis all right so like when they
all
regardless whether you're liberal or
conservative or trying to figure out how
to pay 10 bucks for a
gallon of milk exactly um yeah when when
they have nothing to eat so they so they
they eat the top i get it but the
i would love nothing more than to see
this i would love love love love love to
see this but i
let's be real if i'm working in obama's
camp why am i ever if he's like what do
you guys think i should do this now he's
thinking i should sit at that table
because i'm gonna i'm gonna talk circles
around this guy he probably saw the
debates and i was like i would have
destroyed this dude in the debate
he would like he wants the smoke obama
wants to smoke
every single person in his camp is going
dude what do you benefit from this
you're not you don't have any office to
run for trump is still up for reelection
trump this makes all the sense in the
world if i'm at obama's camp i'm like
what what is this fight for
yeah you got you gain nothing by doing
this you can gain nothing you can just
lose everything why would you even sit
at that table
what what's the he doesn't need the
money pat right
hold on hang on three years from now
with inflation pack of salems could be
two and a half million bucks i could use
a little exchange
oh it was there it was okay it was a
little elvis but it was it was it was 50
50 there
you should have led with the let me know
i think there's more i think there's
more
uh idealist inside obama than react
what's the pitch i don't think the
money's the pitch to obama what's the
pitch
i i think obama still appreciates
and wants relevance it's got to be
bigger than i don't think that's what it
is i think obama i think
i think what you said is one i think to
obama
uh you know it's you don't you think
relevance and legacy matters to him
i think he may be the coolest
cat we've had as a president uh
i've ever seen minus reagan remember
what i said
i didn't say a uh policies
you ever seen obama lose his mind have
you ever seen obama
flip out smooth maybe maybe four times
five times the entire eight years i
don't think i've ever seen him i don't
think i've ever seen
obama angry where he snaps
in a way where some of these other guys
have snapped i don't think i've ever
seen any
any time that take place obama doesn't
if obama wants to do whatever obama
wants to do
obama's going to i'm always at a point
right now young guy he's still got a lot
of living to do
he's going to stay relevant he can do
whatever he wants to do people are going
to want to participate
he's not even 16. he had to remember
that's going crazy yeah i i don't think
he's uh
sitting there worried about if he's
going to get another project this has
simply got to come from a point of
okay um
i've done what i've done but can you
imagine because think about it this way
the whole story of lawrence miller the
book barbarians to bureaucrats that
every
society goes through a few different
phases you got the prophet you got the
barbarian
which profit in this setting would be
who the founding fathers
barbarians would be who the industrial
revolution the soldiers that went out
there and they fought for freedom it's
okay that's not him lincoln and teddy
roosevelt builders and the explorer you
put rockefeller jp morgan chase
carnegies that's the builder and the
explorer then he got the
administrators administrators are who
the lawyers let's put some laws together
right
so it starts with eisenhower right so
then you got so that's taxes 1913 right
1906.
that's when uh sec you know you got all
that other stuff that comes in
income tax starts at 1913 end of world
war one so so then after that you have
the bureaucrats and aristocrats that's
the last phase
and you know what happens when you get
the bureaucrats and aristocracies
then comes the fall we are at the
bureaucrats and aristocrats phase
here's the part if obama if president
obama wants to be known
as the synergist synergist
that brought it together if obama wants
to be known as the
synergist there will there will only be
one in this area there won't be six
synergies if you want to be a synergist
where you bring it together you have a
level that you go to that you're in a
league of your own
that's all there is to it right now so
his legacy is one of division
there's no way that he can a lot of
people will say that but a lot of people
will say that about trump as well you
can't just say it on one side a lot of
people will say the letters either
opposite what i'm trying to say is both
of them will be able to say look
set aside the money i don't even care
what you do with the money i want you to
give it to the following charity here
but
you know et cetera et cetera great hey
maybe they'll they'll even contact me
and they'll say if you get to 200
million dollars we'll do it i'll go
raise the money
i don't have a problem with the money
whatever the number is we'll go raise
the money if they want to happen
and maybe we'll even do this that it's
official we're doing and we're going to
give the money to
whoever the charity may be we'll pull
that off that is not a challenge to do
but a synergist is a permanent
legacy that will be talked about for
hundreds
and hundreds of years that is a very
very unique place to be
bring it to the lowest level bring it to
the lowest level let's go to the lowest
lowest level okay
people are texting me right now saying
pat i will put a half a million dollars
right now i'll put a quarter million
dollars right now these are friends of
mine that are business people say this
guy
i will put up a hundred thousand dollars
right now for that interview okay so
that's individual chats what's happening
here
i i'm who's putting money on us i don't
know what's going on here let me go back
to my point here tom
so so to go back to this thing uh
synergist senator jefferson one yeah so
okay go back to your family go
go back to your family go to your family
and think about
the two relatives that nobody could have
brought them together
who are the two relatives no you don't
need to say the names but you know
exactly what i'm talking about oh yeah
every family has them here's a question
did they ever come together it took a
death
who brought them together the death of
my grandmother that okay it took the
death of a grandmother took a death okay
so the death could be what the fall of
an empire oh yeah okay sure so do you
remember yours you don't need to say who
it is but
did that ever happen your family yeah it
was my
parents getting married and they both
have told me what happened and who was
there
it was amazing and so the marriage
brought them together the wedding itself
brought them together but then at the
reception no bad words were spoken but
they went their ways so my mom and dad
said they'll never be in the same room
together once they got a divorce
from from july 15th excuse me they were
in the same pew in the front row
together
for 60 minutes for the wedding and
everybody was shocked and afterwards
they were very polite but they
left so my so your point so july 1589 we
escaped iran that was the last time my
mom and dad were in the same room
together
but when they got a divorce my mom said
i'll never be in the same room as your
dad my dad said they'll never be in the
same room with your mom
i said great no problem i'm getting
married so they're coming so we haven't
got an invitation
that's because you're not invited yet
they said what do you mean we're not
invited so you think the first time
you're going to meet each other
at my wedding do you think it's a
one-room wedding yeah so i said you
think you
i said the only way you're invited to
the wedding is if you guys are willing
to sit down and have a conversation to
get a mom and dad came together
at my house they spent three hours
together after
20 years of not being the same room and
then i said are you guys
able to do this we can then we did my
wedding pictures right now every time i
look at the what do you call it the
family wedding pictures
you see the picture there it's so every
time i watch it i crack up because
nobody knows the
politics behind it to me i look at my
dad's face in my mom's face
it's only two faces i look at when i
look at that picture right there's
classic
the point is this in every family
someone unites
i call it the dog mentality diffuse
unify glue diffuse unify
glue diffuse unify glue you have to
diffuse the issues that we have today
in order to unify and be the glue glue
brings people together
the media is the complete opposite is
divide
divide divide that's all they do
whatever they can do that impose
conflicts against each other is divide
divide divide
we want to diffuse we want to unify we
want to be glue
if these guys were to come together it
wouldn't be for the money
i agree if they have a number that they
want us to raise and make this happen
we'll go out there make it happen
i don't even want this thing to be some
people call me they said you're probably
going to go sell this on pay-per-view
you're going to go sell this to abc
you're going to go sell this to this
that's what i don't want to do matter of
fact i'll even do it in a way to not
even monetize this for people to realize
this needs to happen this is not about a
monetization type of a stuff this is we
need to have this thing to become a
reality if you want this thing to happen
let's go out there and do it i want to
see this happen because i'd like to look
back and say okay look
in reality who has more experience when
it comes down to
the the the stuff that happens at u.s
government us
trump or obama oh my god trump obama
trump it'll
okay great well let's come on down let's
sit down here's how i see it
when i process this the reason why i
haven't announced it for the last five
weeks what's a week before fourth of
july july you'd say june 28th
so june 28 to today's what exactly four
weeks right it was a saturday
saturday or sunday sunday we had a
gathering for i don't know what what it
was about
matter of fact no i'm sorry it was a
week before brooklyn was born so it was
like july
june 20th or something baby shower at
the house i don't even remember what the
date was for that
yeah was it mid-june it's got to be six
weeks ago anyway right before
it was before that because i was still
in uh dallas and you called me tom what
do you think of
this and this is this and i said let's
process this i love the idea i'll see
you next week it was in your old place
in boca
yeah you had the whole team over there
and then things were kind of settling
down and
you know we were like dude you're about
to have your fourth kid man you were
like man you had like this moment of
like reservation like i i hope that she
has the same country that my other kids
are growing up in
and that's and that's when i was like
well okay yeah this is these are tense
times for sure man
and you were like okay what can i do i'm
going to bring i'm going to bring obama
and trump together and we were like uh
okay how are you going to do that no no
i'm going to do it uh
i i i thought about it here's what i
thought about so if this happens
china's going gonna have a few steps
back to take
okay uh number two you know you know
what i'd like to see happen with this
first we do the
the discourse the civil discourse for
them to go back and forth i think
neither one of them is scared of the
other one i know
i think obama's up for it and i think
trump is definitely up for it
i think neither one of them is sitting
there saying i will never you know i
think it's more the only reason this
people
talk circles around trump i think i
think i think the only people that will
not make this happen is the people
around them
it's the only people i think trump wants
to do it i think obama would love to do
it
and i think you know what i'm most
excited about this here's what i'm most
excited about this
this is what would make my day if this
were to happen say they come down they
have a conversation together
okay here's my favorite part afterwards
is for them to go and spend a couple
hours just by themselves with nobody
being around
just talk no one to be around i got a
playground
no no no and i'm being serious right now
no no
camera no audio no nothing no fan base
no advisor on your side no advisor on
the other side just the two of you
talk sometimes you gotta talk about
yourself to the person that's your enemy
and just sit down and say whatever the
hell you want to say that's not on
camera what do you want to tell them
talk to each other i i can i i see that
being
way way way less likely than the actual
well hang on i
i don't i don't know i don't i don't see
it less likely let me let me let me
let me interrupt yeah go back and look
what happened to camp david peace
accords
they took a break and without their
handlers they were all going to take a
break and just go
amongst themselves carter over here
begging over here set out over here
but bagan and sadat took a walk through
the woods
it's not really woods it's paths at camp
david together without their handlers
and without the media
and they say that there were
breakthrough elements on that walk
and it was away from the cameras pat i
don't know if you've been studying this
or anything but what you're saying
history shows it's correct history shows
it right a little time together one on
one
would facilitate and it happened i don't
think that it wouldn't i just think
i can't see the handlers letting it
happen i can't see the teams letting it
happen
we live in a time guys build back better
is everywhere
but a year before they broke it they're
going to build it back better they're
the ones that
broke it but they're the ones that would
do it they're the ones that would do it
if there's any two people that would do
it as a two of them
like you know it's it's like it's like
go play
around the golf with nobody just secret
service outside but nobody can hear your
conversations
go spend a couple hours together what
does the world do if they see these two
guys golfing
18 holes nine holes they've experienced
something only 40 other people on earth
have ever experienced
being they've that's it 43 other have
experienced that's it
right so yeah so absolutely but at this
point
again this is the part i does obama
think for himself or is he afraid of
what other
people tell him what to do does obama is
you think obama's going to be the person
that's going to say
hey don't say that obama and obama's
like okay i'm not going to say it i i
think there are elements of that yeah
i don't know i disagree i think obama
knows what he's all about
as far as as far as maybe some things
that will not work in the campaign
i agree don't wear this tie wear this
you know that kind of stuff of course
he's going okay you're the expert in
this area you think someone's going to
be able to say hey
don't say that policy or this or that or
you know okay i'm so sorry i'm not going
to do that i don't i think he's going to
do what he's going to do
and i think trump's going to do what
trump's going to do heck we know when he
was president nobody could tell him what
to do some of the stuff he would do
you're like
that was not good i think obama if obama
was completely autonomous he would have
extended the bush tax cuts
i don't think so if obama was autonomous
would it be clearly autonomous would he
have
extended the bush tax cuts but that was
that was a part of his
message he felt the solution was to
raise taxes
he felt that was the solution i don't
okay that's how he extended the bush tax
cuts that's i'm not
so what i'm saying is i i don't i don't
know if
i i i see barack obama
[Music]
i see donald trump less this way but i
see barack obama more as the the front
man of a team
than as a an individual driving force
uh i don't know i see differently i see
i see
he's at a phase of his life did you see
his interview with letterman did you see
his interview when he did letterman
have you seen some of the stuff that
he's done after presidency i've seen all
his work
and he looks like a kind of guy that
just wants to have his fun
and live his life and you see him with
bruce springsteen right now they got
their
you know podcast going on that they're
doing what they're doing and by the way
this would
in another way even if obama did
something like this imagine
what it's going to do to everything else
i mean imagine how
this drives everything else he's
currently working on maybe he wants to
show a new version of himself sometimes
the biggest part about you know we
talked about this i was given a talk uh
last week
in dallas there was like a thousand guys
i'm at this event called eight percent
nation i was kind of telling you about
this and at the top i talked about two
topics
and i gave the story of jane elliot that
tom shared with me the story of the
third grade teacher and we talked about
propaganda and gaslight
gaslighting one of the things i talked
about is i said
if you're not too careful like in high
school
in junior high school what was gerard's
reputation
what did 50 other kids think of gerard
gerrard was who
in junior high school junior high school
eighth grade who was gerard
a little chubby kid got bullied and uh
was good at sports but pretty shy okay
there you go let's stay there
who what was what did kids say about tom
ellsworth in eighth grade
three things what you joke too much you
talk too much but you're a smart guy and
i wanna be
work with you on projects okay perfect
go to senior year what do they say about
tom ellsworth
what do they say about gerard and senior
that dude's the man really
seriously yeah okay so you went from
eighth grade
shy kid chubby decent athlete but you
know
football freshman year changed
everything but weight room senior year
yeah
he's the man three senior year who were
you senior year uh
people knew i was really smart i still
joked a little too much i still talked a
little too much
but people said you're gonna do
something okay now go to 30 years old
what was your reputation at 30 years old
matter of fact just go to 25 you
graduated from college what are you
doing at 25
what was your reputation at 25 uh
it was my last year in the minor leagues
was probably somebody that was hanging
on to a dream too long
probably somebody was staying at the
party too long okay so that's 25. yeah
were you were you fun to party with
did you have the reputation probably two
months yeah okay tom 25 what was tom's
reputation
uh i was
so that was my 25 years old was my
second job it was at la cellular and
i had gotten promoted twice because i
just got it done
and i think the reputation without any
ego in it was he gets it done
okay so here's what i'm going to with
this today
what's tom's reputation today what's
gerard's reputation today
go to your reputation today right
whatever it may be you don't have to say
just think about it right
here's the point i'm trying to make to
you how many times
have you recreated your reputation
and your identity how many times many
many times
and by the way some are currently going
through maybe trying to recreate our
their identity right some of us may be
going through recreating our identity
right now nobody knows about it we want
to be known as hey this is what i've
been known for for the last five years
i'm going to work on xyz right
i don't know i think obama may be
wanting to recreate his identity to come
out and say hey
you know this is my position now i know
a lot of you guys have put me in this
box as i'm this person
and some of you guys have put me in the
boxes i'm this person but i kind of want
to recreate my identity this is who i
really am at this phase of my life based
on the experiences i've had
that that's what i foresee if this were
to happen
it would be because i'm not who any of
you guys think
i am there's a part of me of who i am
that you think i am yes that is who i am
but there's a part of me you know
nothing about i am at this phase of my
life and i want to be known for
that and a synergist to me i don't think
the book power versus force you ever
read the book power versus force by
david
can you pull up power versus force chart
pull up power versus force
charge yeah the rainbow the rainbow
triangle yeah if you pull up power
versus forces
a chart go to images so this is what he
talks about in this book it's a powerful
book by the way
i read this 20 years ago if you can make
it bigger so everybody can see it okay
there you go lowest level of where to be
is shame
okay this is a level of consciousness it
goes from shame to guilt to apathy to
grief to fear to desire to anger to
pride
first level of consciousness where
you're actually becoming a leader and
living a bit of a
freer life is courage then it's
neutrality neutrality is you can
entertain opposing conversations
then you're willing to have a
conversation you're willing to be open
to it
then your acceptance of people i accept
the fact that you're different than me i
accept the fact that we have differences
then it's reason you have the ability to
reason let's reason an issue together
then it goes to love joy peace
enlightenment right a
synergist is loving above
a synergist is love and above you want
to be a synergist
let's make this happen you want to be a
synergist let's make this happen i think
in this year if you look at trump or
obama
you'd probably put trump in what level
what level would you put trump
what level would you put obama if you
put it there uh
trump somewhere between pride and
courage okay obama
acceptance and reason
[Music]
courage yeah and i'd put them in the
same place
so both in the same place okay maybe
somebody say hi somebody say lord but
the point is if you want to get to the
next level
where your legacy say this guy you've
reunited america
i think that's that's a that's a long
time i don't think it would take a lot
of
uh courage for him to sit down with with
you or or trump
i think that that's something that he
would welcome he would want to do the
courage is standing up to his team
that's going to tell him there's nothing
in this for you that more importantly
barack there's nothing in this for us
there's nothing in this room he has to
love america more than dnc
he has to love america more than he
loves the dnc oh i don't know if he does
i don't think that's the question he has
to love america more than he loves
democrats i don't know if there's a
democrat that i
know right now that loves america more
than they love the democratic party yeah
mansion would be america more than
democrats okay i don't know but yeah
mansion would be mentioned would be a
guy that loves america more than the
democratic and i think there's a few
others as well by the way
but if obama's at a point right now that
it's more america
than a democratic party you would do to
sit down
i'm just saying if it is if it's really
america more than your party you would
do to sit down
if it's if it's really more america than
the republican party
trump would do to sit down i think trump
doesn't sit down no problem no problem
does it he does it no
problem but it's advantageous in
fairness
to him it's it's political more than it
is contagious for him to do it
do you think it do you think it helps
him more you think it helps trump more
if this becomes a reality
i but i don't think i don't see this as
a debate i don't i see this i don't
either
yeah i almost want to bring them
together i ask literally three four five
questions and then they go
go for it that's that's my only outcome
is not even to ask any ques it's not
like so tell me
it's okay boom boom boom then i say look
what questions do you have for one
another
you know we have a few different issues
to go through i think these are the
things that
america would like to know uh what are
your thoughts on these three different
issues i'd be curious enough if you guys
have questions for each other how do we
get here
and then president obama asked trump
questions president trump asked obama a
question we just sit there and listen
and it can go 90 minutes where no one's
saying anything but they're talking to
each other
that's what i think the world wants to
see this is not like a
moderator so tell me you got two minutes
for an answer no this is not that
this is what's really on your mind yeah
what how do you think we got here
what part of it do you think is on your
side what part of you think is on their
side and to your point you know who
really would probably be the most pissed
off is the extremes
like the the crazy maggot right and
crazy
would hate that they'd hate it they
would hate this aoc would hit it yeah
yeah bernie would hate it which which is
why i want to see it all the more
because i don't think they love america
i think they're kind of
on the marxist side of things sorry but
well that's the whole buildback better
thing that i was talking about before
this the global thing right
the buildback better things were
quantifiably
like quantifiably better than they've
ever been
before humans had more access to
nutrients we were safer
their people were living longer humanity
three years ago
had never reached the levels that we
reached we have we basically have
recreational
in in 80 years we went from horse and
buggy to recreational space flights
you know what i'm saying like we're
killing it as a species
but we're being presented with this idea
that that that you know london bridge is
falling down
we have to build back better this thing
was the system wasn't working
dude it's it's marxist bs you can't sell
revolution
in times of prosperity so they have to
present this image that that things were
crumbling and they weren't
things were going great do we do we have
the phone ready if i'm calling somebody
i got somebody here that just
wants to make a commitment yes you can
and a
good sized commitment to make this
happen uh
let me know you can plug in your phone
too if you want
uh let me know if we're don't forget to
plug in the it's plugged in just so you
guys know right now it's about
your name hang on once i gotta state my
name give me one second
okay so i'm going to call them up this
is aaron um
aaron is the number is using robokiller
to screen their calls no problem kai can
you pull up a retcon jim
and i'll try to connect redcondjim is a
big jim here uh aaron this is patrickbet
david
he is the ceo and founder of retcon one
it's not just a gym it's also a
supplement company
that they do extremely well all our guys
here go to their gym and use their
supplements
and aaron is known in the bodybuilding
world that is himself aaron how are you
aaron can you can you hear us
how you doing buddy how you feeling
good good how are you i'm very good i'm
very good thanks for taking
this call i know you uh messaged me
yesterday and you commented yesterday
and we went back and forth and i said
are you willing to say that on the
podcast and you agreed so if you don't
mind telling the viewer
what was your reaction when you saw that
do you think it's a good idea and if yes
why
yeah so both me and my wife uh saw it
and she commented me check this out
and uh i think it's a fantastic idea and
uh something needs to happen to save
this country
and uh i feel like uh why not you why
not these two guys get together and
and start hashing it out they're two
obviously very well respected
people from each individual party and i
thought it was a great idea and i said
hey man
how can i help can i throw in some money
and make it sweeten up the pot
if we're for get these guys together and
aaron if you don't mind
if the audience doesn't know you we have
your picture up right now on
the podcast do you mind sharing with
folks what it is you do yourself
what does you and your wife do sure well
i am the uh the founder of redcon1 which
is the
fastest growing sports supplement
company in the world we're sold in 90
countries
uh worldwide walmart united states
military
um vitamin shop gnc et cetera so uh
we do that and then we also run the red
colon foundation which gives back to
military families
in need and very patriotic
brands me and my wife are both very
patriotic dariel my wife helps run the
foundation and
we try to do things to help give back
you know and we've been very fortunate
in this life to
be able to do that and and uh you know
it was
great uh spending time with your wife
and your
son i believe that was on my daughter's
birthday this was what uh
six two months ago i think maybe two and
a half months ago or something like that
whatever may was so two months ago
and uh spend time with the family so go
ahead
dog i wish i would have been uh been
there at the party i didn't even know uh
i didn't even know until after the fact
and
jerryl said it was a great party and
aiden my son uh loves your daughter so
very cool last night my daughter comes
and
my my wife sends me videos and my
wife's recording my daughter she sent me
private videos about this guy she met in
school
and she says the name and my daughter
starts turning red he says i met this
guy
and we like him and i like him and he
likes me and i come home last night i'm
like so
senna tell me about this guy you met and
i give the guy's name and she starts
turning red and she runs away she don't
want to talk about him anyway she's
already flirting with guys it concerns
me
big time long term but it is what it is
so aaron
you saying that are you comfortable
sharing with the audience how much
you're willing to support this cause if
it were to become a reality
i'm willing to put up half a million
dollars of our money to uh to help make
it happen and i thought
if they're more people out there like me
businessmen who
uh who are patriotic love our country
and think this is a good idea which i
think a lot of people
will i think it uh hopefully i'm the
first person to do this out of many
people
that would be willing to put up money
and help make it happen
well brother i appreciate you for doing
that uh
you know there's nothing like having
other people that love this country as
much as we do and the fact that you're
not just saying it but you're doing it
says a lot about what you and your wife
uh are willing to to do to reunite this
country and uh
uh uh definitely appreciate you doing
that and folks if you're listening this
is aaron singerman ceo and founder of
retcon
uh aaron maybe we'll have you on here to
uh to speak about this as this thing
gets uh
deeper and deeper into this possibly
happening
you let me know patrick i'm just down
the road we're we're based in boca not
too far from you
all good i appreciate i definitely will
i'll text you right afterwards
uh that's what patrick i've been trying
to get you to the gym dude i got to tell
you
no joke i've had by the way for full
disclos disclosure
i am not a fan of uh uh protein bars i'm
not a fan of these things are i've had
all of them and i eat it because i'm
forced to eat it or protein drinks i
drink these drinks because i'm forced to
drink them
your stuff tastes amazing and i'm being
dead serious guys
your stuff that you sent tastes amazing
i got 30 employees here 35 employees at
the valuetainment media
i don't know how many of them go to your
gym but that's all they talk about when
they go to you they swear by retcon
and i'm gonna tell you this on camera on
the podcast i'm gonna come stop by your
gym today's what today's thursday
i'm gonna come stop by your gym within
the next 24 hours i'll come to your
place and check out your gym next 24
hours
let me know and i'll be sure to be there
to roll out the red carpet the gym
is a passion project so it's it's for
fun for us and you'll see you'll you'll
get the feeling
brother i'm looking forward to it i am
looking forward to it i'm gonna text you
i'm looking forward to we'll go together
thanks buddy appreciate you take care
bye bye bye bye-bye
half a million dollars okay first half a
million dollars we got right there so
now it's no longer 5 million it's five
5.5 million and i got another one here
uh alfred i am calling you here and by
the way anybody that's listening to this
here's what i'm gonna do
anybody that's listening to this
whatever you decide to donate on super
chat today
a hundred percent of what you give on
super chat today
a hundred percent of it whatever you
give five dollars ten dollars a hundred
dollars a thousand dollars whatever it
is
i'm gonna use a hundred percent of it
and we're going to create a what do you
call a a uh
uh barometer that tracks it and we can
obviously start a gofundme
charity tomorrow yeah we need to create
a thermometer to see how much we're
raising for this and we'll keep a track
of it until it finally becomes a reality
and this thing creates momentum and so
whatever you give on super chat today is
going to go to this and fyi if it
doesn't end up becoming a reality
we will figure out a way to give it away
to a scholarship or a charity and we'll
make that announcement exactly the
dollar amount that we raise
but let me call the next person alfred i
am calling you
next alfred himself runs a uh
let's see if we can get a hold of alfred
alfred if you're listening i am calling
you buddy
i am ready to to make a donation of 400
billion boulevards
um so buck is what you want to do
how much did 400 boulevards did hey pbd
i just picked up my phone
and um i posted this on linkedin my
socials and i just did a quick check
there
i was checking the stats right now i'm
running
this morning it's just it's on fire and
it's running
25 to 125 to 2 on the likes
dislike people that want to see this
happen that's correct
how you doing buddy good good how are
you
i'm doing very good i'm doing very so
where you are right now it's 7 25
california time alfred uh
uh uh can you tell everybody what
business you're in and what you do
oh man uh 20 21 years when
transportation
build a platform for transportation
uh how many loads you guys do per month
how many loads you guys do per month how
many branches do you have how many
employees do you have
give us optics or else i'm gonna tell
everybody how big you guys are because i
think people need to know
uh we you know we pretty much move
approximately a thousand trucks a day
a day uh a day yes somewhere on there
and uh we have about maybe three to four
thousand sales guys around the corner in
the world moving
right here
sales guys around the world okay uh top
line revenue shy of half a billion
dollars alfred what do you think about
this
idea of getting president trump and
president obama sit together
man when i when i heard it was
unbelievable honestly
i can't even believe you even thought
about that i think obviously
you know you and i being immigrants
coming to this country understanding the
you know the values and how amazing this
country is and
uh definitely want to be part of the
solution no question about it
uh and i i even text you i said
maybe uh the first thing is to getting
the wives together
maybe that might be the first uh
shot getting these two guys together uh
money might be more relevant to them
than them but obviously if you can get
those two big boys together that can
definitely make a lot of [ __ ]
change are you are you willing to
support it are you willing to support
and throw a couple dollars of couple uh
you know dollars towards this project of
course i text you about that i said look
uh i'll put 100 grand
no no question about it if you can get
this done i'm more willing to be
another hundred thousand dollars so now
we're at 5.6 million dollars the numbers
have changed so alfred a hundred
thousand dollars
towards uh this becoming a reality
brother appreciate you
i am uh i miss you and i can't wait when
i'm in la for us to go to rafi's place
together and i know we're talking right
now about figuring something out
yeah for sure
got it man you got it take care you say
hello to everybody my man i will bye bye
bye bye bye
so we're at 5.6 million now okay and and
you got the six hundred thousand dollars
and the last four minutes was great okay
just wanna let you know we haven't even
started yet right so we're at 5.6
million dollars a lot of bolivares
it's just a couple of the text messages
that got through the clutter that got to
you
imagine everything else yeah i'll
contribute i get paid this friday so
i'll get with you then tell your boss to
tell you a little bit more you know what
seriously ask for a raise or something
by the way we got a we got a
a bunch of people just all of a sudden
started let me see here myron hyman
twenty dollars myron have another five
dollars he threw twenty five dollars
into a thank you
sirfania twenty bucks jorge lopez twenty
uh five dollars
uh arsenal fan uh five dollars my small
contribution to getting these two glides
in the same room together well
appreciate you everything helps
dnd furniture five dollars uh he says a
thousand dollars but it only says five
dollars so you may want to update that
alex h 20 bucks here's a little one i
appreciate that
supreme sean gave another 20. uh i love
this country and i love this podcast
thank you terson tash go america 25
bucks daryl
hamill make it happen pbd 50 bucks thank
you daryl willy figueroa another 50
kevin fischer ten dollars just jen 25
make it happen cooper lobo 10 bucks uh
george van criptic 100 i would love to
see that interview happen as well
home of the free 10 bucks from hugo
munoz
it would be very i mean seriously if
this were to ever happen
i mean i think the spirit in america
would go to a whole different level
media would media lose their minds oh
yeah would would the folks in media lose
their minds if this were to happen
good even better i think they would lose
their minds if something like this were
to happen so folks again
if you want to dnd furniture just give
another hundred dollars jordan becker
just gave another 50
if some of you are listening and you
want them
you know people that may want to
contribute at a higher number the next
phase right now is asking elon musk to
match 50 million dollars
going after bezos to see if he'd want to
put up 10 million dollars going after
folks like that so if you've seen the
video it's on my twitter i've pinned it
all the way at the top
if any one of you guys want to go talk
to the
congressman media other billionaires
people you may know people you may
do business with friends family anyone
if you know
anybody to get this in front of we are
barely i announced this yesterday
so you have to know that this campaign
is probably going to go on for some time
now to talk about this
to see how much money whether it's
mckenzie based oats whether it's
uh bezos himself whether it's buffett
whether it's any of these guys like
lindell who are talking to you
there could be another one there right
exactly so if anybody wants to see this
happen
let's go make this a reality and get
these two gentlemen
in there to help them synergize and
unify america so
but if you do want to make a bigger
contribution message us directly
send me a message if it's more than if
you're willing to match a
fifty thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars ten thousand dollars a
million dollars five million dollars
contact us directly i would love to have
you make the announcement on the podcast
with the rest of us here okay
thoughts six hundred thousand dollars in
a few minutes i can't believe you just
raised a hundred thousand dollars a
minute live on the year that's so that's
there you go
and that's just the beginning tom i
think this shows you the undercurrent
that what
americans want is things to come
together americans want things to come
together
and as much as they fight and as much as
we bicker
remember we're only one morning on 9 11
from coming together and demonstrating
just how unified we really are
but but do we really fight and bigger
that much tom or does the media
tell us that things like this this is
what i'm talking about like
the the world that the media tells me
exists every night it's not the world i
wake up no it's
really not though no no regardless of
the point of manipulation we do fight in
bicker
now are we manipulated into a lot of
this damn straight
but we're only one moment and i would
never want to see it again in my
lifetime we're only one moment on one
morning like september 11th from coming
together
yeah i guess but i mean look just look
at this room you know you've got you've
got david you got vanessa you got kai
uh kai norway vanessa
venezuela tom you're from california new
jersey
iran and then california david um
colombia soviet russia was it colombia
that's columbia okay
the soviets
it's not a communist the uh
the whole idea in this office you come
through this office you walk through
nothing but and it's organic diversity
it's not forced diversity pat didn't
hire any of these people to fit into a
box there's no
there's no uh diversity inclusivity
objective here
and this is the most diverse environment
i've ever worked in
so i i and these are people from
different walks of life that have
different views
and we sit and we have fun in this
office we joke with each other every day
we even hang out at this is a probably
the most together office i've ever been
in in a creative environment we played
volleyball together last night kai lost
to me and mickey by the way
kai and paul he's from norway 22 years
old goalie he lost yesterday i mean it
was never going to happen again
my texts was blowing up last night with
the fact that kai lost
dude so what i'm saying i guess and i'm
sorry i'm rambling here but the point
i'm trying to make is
that if the environment cnn told me was
reality this office couldn't exist the
way it exists
it just couldn't and i agree and that's
just the beginning by the way that's
just the beginning of what uh
we plan on doing here go ahead tom
accept adam
we gotta make it we gotta make a fence
around adam i love the sewing man mafia
i love adam i love the guy by the way
fyi did you guys hear about what
happened with youtube we can move on
with the story going to the different
story did you guys hear about the fact
that
youtube is a proven juggernaut that
rivals
netflix in the streaming views let me
give you some stats on this so google
parent company alphabet delivered
another monster earnings
report tuesday one of the brightest bits
came from youtube which booked a
whopping
ready seven billion dollars in
advertising revenue last quarter
quarterly revenue is on par
with netflix and it's growing at a
faster rate alphabet said youtube
booked 7 billion in ad revenue last
quarter that's 83
from a year ago compared to compare that
to
netflix's 7.3 billion dollars in revenue
booked in the same period netflix's
revenue grew 19.4
from a year ago by the way that's kai is
that not interesting to know that
youtube grew by 83
versus netflix is 19 that's wow that
that's pretty well to think with youtube
television viewing has grown
faster than ever before the company said
120 million people watch
youtube on tv last month
up from 100 million per a month last
year
uh up from a 100 million a month from
last year's 20
youtube's tick tock rival is also
growing short term video is the dominant
trend on social media today
with tick tocks leading on charge
youtube has its own short term uh short
form video service youtube short
designed to compete with tic toc
alphabet didn't disclose how many people
are using shoe tube shorts but said
view and metrics jumped from 6.5 billion
views per day
in march to 15 billion views a day in
the end of last quarter so
youtube beating netflix tom are you
surprised by this
no we kind of talked about a little bit
of this we were talking about disney
plus like about a month and a half ago
here on the podcast
so remember covid year spurred
everything and the disney plus launch
happened
at the you know orgasmic perfect
launch point for disney plus for
everybody was in the house
and everybody wanted to watch tv and
disney plus was offended with hulu
was a great over-the-top uh service well
i think what's also happening is you
gotta remember we're talking about the
youtube viewership that's web
online ad supported over the last course
of the last year
so it doesn't surprise me and i'm i'm
really seeing
you know yet abc nbc cbs and i that was
the original big three
before the consolidations and cw went
away and fox remember all that
well i think what you have right now
you've got the disney monolith
you have youtube because remember as
youtube television as well as youtube
online
etc and then you've got um you know
tick tock and i think what's interesting
about tick tock what we kind of
jumped over and i don't know if you guys
covered this or not tic toc is only the
second
company ever to have three billion
downloads right facebook was number one
tick tock was number two
my understanding and so i think the
plates are shifting and what we're
seeing is a big
three emerge in both streaming and
entertainment disney plus and hulu
and then youtube with youtube tv
and then you've got you know snap's not
really doing its thing you have facebook
instagram
waiting in the lobby to go into congress
sir and um
and then tick tock that's what i think
is going on we're seeing big three
emerge like we've seen in other
industries
i think um well look there's two
different
sides of this there's two different
things at play all right there is
the idea of of a model right you have
the two different models you have the
subscription versus the freemium model
but then you also have the restriction
of speech
and curation versus choice right like if
you go on netflix especially
over the last two three years uh it's
been
remarkably um look it's basically social
engineering right i mean the amount of
f we talk about all the time and i know
i'm sounding like johnny right wing
again but it's just this is the truth of
it like
everything has a left wing
progressive messaging so it turns people
off if i go to a netflix original i just
immediately think okay it's going to be
orange is the new black it's going to be
this it's going to be that it's going to
have the same messaging i'm not
interested in it
yeah what are they telling me what what
concept are they selling it's kind of
the same thing with disney plus
on youtube i have the choice then like i
can watch what they what they suggest
but i have the choice to search for
anything that i want i'm on youtube all
the time and i find myself on tik tok
all the time now as well that algorithm
gets to know you pretty pretty well so
you you're
you're finding something you know in our
industry it's really interesting because
you know we're in the content creation
industry how do you
create an environment where people are
willing to pay
for content when they've grown their
entire life being entertained for free
and also how do you present them with
content when they themselves have chosen
the content that they want their whole
life
this is how itunes changed the game and
this is how youtube is
defeating netflix long-term who wins
netflix or youtube i think free choice
wins man
the the ability to choose exactly what
you want to watch
when you want to watch and to be able to
watch it for free
is it's an unbeatable i don't think
long-term netflix or youtube wins folks
if you're watching this long-term who
wins
netflix or youtube i think you're right
we're talking about two different things
we're talking about long-form creation
and episodical that netflix does which
takes longer to build
millions and millions and millions of
dollars per new show concept
versus independently ran channels where
people are creating their own correct
yeah so who wins long term uh youtube
youtube on that platform wins long term
and i think they're going to find out
pretty quick that they need to allow the
conservative
voice a little bit more latitude and i
think they're going to learn that thanks
to the
facebook hearings that are coming up you
think so because right now they're
probably sitting there saying our
strategy is working we're up 83 percent
you don't know what you're talking about
19 no no no netflix is up 19
youtube is up 83 you think youtube is
saying tom our strategy is working well
everybody was talking about netflix a
year ago we're whooping their ass
they're at 19 we're doing 4x what
they're doing and more so yes we're
going to stick together
the strategy is working well and you're
absolutely correct yeah and but
let's rewind a bit make sure everybody
hears what i just said
facebook is heading into hearings right
they're coming yeah
you've got all the new people that are
chairing ftc and you hear the statements
they're making even yesterday yeah
uh those people are not not happy with
facebook and the targeting
and facebook is trying to pander to the
americans
by writing a foil board with an american
flag wall
john denver music plays right so i
i think right now are youtube's sales
executives
thinking no they're exactly what you're
saying pat you're right
but are they strategically thinking we
better keep our eye on this uh
government thing because if facebook
gets moved on this then they're going to
move us too
we've actually seen this play out guys
but long term it's an open
field even if they censor it later it's
an open field netflix is a cd
you might have one show that you really
want on netflix you want to watch house
and cars so you got netflix yeah
same way when when i wanted i wanted to
listen to rough rider's anthem i had to
buy
it's dark and hell's hot i had to buy
dmx's whole cd right that's netflix you
got to buy the platform to get that one
show
where i see youtube as itunes i could
just pick the one thing that i like and
i don't and then i'll go to something
else so
we saw this play out itunes destroyed
the cd industry there's no cds anymore
you don't need to buy a whole i think
that's a great
metaphor that's that's where we're at
we've seen you
guys you know so long although every
time
every now and then netflix does
something good like drive to survive
so so so question though for you
it's unscripted who is less likely to
have a competitor
take market share away from them okay
facebook
youtube or twitter who is the least
likely to have a direct competitor and
take market share away from i'm talking
a good amount of market share
youtube least like i think so least
likely because the amount of server
space you would have to have to compete
is like remarkable you'd have to like
kind of like competing against a
bottling company like pepsi or coke yeah
okay so who's second least likely do you
agree with them by the way youtube being
number one
yes okay who's your second least likely
facebook or twitter
facebook facebook is second so twitter's
easier to go up against then facebook or
youtube
put it this way facebook tried to
compete with youtube twice they had
facebook watch
and they had igtv they tried to roll out
not one but
two different ips just to try to match
youtube and they they they failed
you agree with them every you agree with
them yes i do
what do you in the middle of an argument
you can add to that is
they were also the first one with the
big bank going out to pay creators
mm-hmm well well facebook tried to
facebook that talk about
years ago yeah had the big bank 3xing
the cpms they were literally covered
they're gonna spend a half a billion
dollars five million at a time on a
hundred different shows remember that
yep
and they and they went over to wme and
wme happily took their money
i think the model in the future is it's
so funny man i was i was talking to
uh to phil about this last night and i'm
like you know he was talking about jake
paul and i'm like this is the future
this is this is not an anomaly it's you
get an x amount of people doing prank
videos then you become a music artist
and you get an x amount of people doing
that and then you do
a podcast you get an x amount of people
doing that you look up you've got a
couple million followers you can do
whatever you want i'm gonna be a boxer
no you're not well there's four million
people willing to watch me that says i
can box
jake buddy come let's have a fight yeah
get a marketplace first talking about
jake paul here's what jake paul just
said yesterday i don't know if you guys
saw that or not jake paul said
claims he and his brother logan paul
will run for president when they turn 35
years old after youtube unboxing careers
this is a son
story jake 24 years old logan 26 years
old will
run for president 2032 during an
interview with overtime jake was asked
who would be more likely to become a u.s
president out of himself or la
laker superstar lebron james and even
though he admitted the basketball
would be more likely to be voted into
the white house and he then announced
his intention to run for president when
he turned 35 years old says i'm running
for president
uh but i'm not even 35 yet my brother
and i would run for president 2032
that's when we're eligible we're still
figuring this thing out i might be
president he might be president i think
we're going to flip a coin and see who
gets to be the president versus who's vp
by the way
i've been saying this for a while that i
think depaul's one of them is going to
be the president i think more likely
either one of them has enough audacity
to do it uh
but i think eventually one of these guys
going to be the president can you see a
president paul you know
why not tom can you see that happening
the
the value of followership influence for
paul to become a president um
you know when has a celebrity
um ever like made it to like a major
political
office i actually accept that uh
wrestler that became
governor of minnesota that's right um oh
yeah
and um schwarzenegger became governor of
california
oh crap it could happen how about the
actor who became a uh
uh uh president two-term and then the
other guy who had a show
for 15 years apprentice that became a
president
so so is it inevitable that one of these
guys going to be a president there there
there you go again i always felt that i
was destined to lead this country
that's more reagan than the other one
was obama by the way the other one was
kind of like elvis presley when i was
thinking about it well i gotta
for obama i gotta smoke a pack of salems
and get the rough voice oh really
so did he smoke salem or no it dude
obama secretly no no no not obama reagan
was reagan a smoker i don't know if
reagan was a smoker early on he was in
all the celebrities everybody was
smoking cigarettes back in the days
man you know dude like this is this is
one of those things like
we're a democratic republic i get it but
man oh man man like
some there's something sometimes where
i'm just like we we kind of should just
go back to like
a council of elders like let's let's
just have a council of elders let's get
like a couple of uh
a couple of oligarchs together and hope
we get the right ones man because like
look give them a podcast let's go for it
man like
you know this one of the one of the the
great things about our government
is that they they force us to believe
that they actually doing something this
entire
all of congress can be done like tinder
we can all have we could all have votes
on our phone every day just right swipe
or left swipe we can do
all their jobs from our phone man so i
who knows dude
who knows i look do you think jake and
logan paul
would be good presidents i bet you
they'd probably be better than than
people would think because again they're
so egocentric and they're so legacy
dependent they would probably get really
good people around them
to implement some some things i i don't
i don't know i
i i would i would love to see
that campaign though i have to be honest
i don't know if i want to live in a
world where jake paul
is my president but i definitely want to
live in a world where jake paul is
running
for president for sure how does it look
like
is it troll county non-stop nonstop
troll county
he just i'd knock you out you know would
it be that kind of an environment or
he steals somebody's tie in the middle
of the debate and then runs around
the auditorium that would be
classic that would be classic if that
were to take place
he'd be the first president with face
tattoos so there's that
is it is it neck tattoos or face tattoos
a little bit of both
is it a little cute little caliber i
don't know if
he's got face tattoos hail to the chief
[Music]
hail to the chief yo this is snoop dogg
i'm out here for my mo
there he is i don't see faces oh i see
neck tattoos i don't see face tattoos he
still has it 15 years to work on that
though
yeah that's he's got time to get a face
tattoo i don't know you know
those nipples presidential are they
president that is
that's pretty so there's there's the
foreign policy hand grenade right there
jake paul face tattoos that's how you
find them face tattoos
oh [ __ ]
hail too he does not face tattoos that's
got to be
that's a head tattoo i guess more than
oh i've seen that before yeah i've seen
that before okay that well that counts
okay all right so he'd be the first to
do that he'd be the first to do that
that were to take place uh
let's see what next story do we go to
here out of all these things that we
have uh
okay china let's talk about china what
happened with china go to page seven
uh with china so our this is uh
china expanding its nuclear capability
scientists say bbc story china is
expanding its capacity to store and
launch nuclear missiles u.s scientists
say
satellite images from jinping jinjang
province and the west of the
country suggest that it's building a
nuclear missile so a
silo field it is the second new silo
field
reported to be under construction
western china last two months the site
could house
about 110 silos which are underground
facilities used for storing and
launching missiles in 2020 china had a
nuclear stockpile
of more than 200 warheads and was aiming
to at least double this amount
the pentagon says the u.s has
approximately 3 800
warheads and in a propaganda video china
threatens to nuke japan after japan vows
to defend taiwan in a now deleted
propaganda video china threatens to nuke
japan
following comments made by japanese
leaders vowing to defend taiwan from
chinese invasion the nearly six minute
video
which was posted to the chinese
communist party sanctioned channel
jigua featured images and videos of
chinese war machines such as tanks and
fighter jets edited into pictures of a
devastated 1940s japan following the
world war ii u.s nuclear strikes
on hiroshima and nagasaki the video
references japan's defeat in world war
ii before promising full-scale war
against the only country to have ever
been nuked
the video also said there will be no
peace
talks tom how much do you love china
what um
well first of all whenever you talk
about china talk about russia because
china and russia are now
really intertwined and russia has leaned
over that way
i mean china just had a meeting with the
taliban leaders of afghanistan yesterday
i don't know if you saw that or not
want to see that the video i mean
they've been supplying weapon stone for
20 years
about time did you actually see that i
did not see that i did not see that
video the foreign minister of china
yesterday met with
the afghani taliban leader yesterday
there you go well here's what's going on
here
people need to understand that
taiwan is a
global semiconductor and market share
play
you know this is the china if china
takes taiwan
what they do if you go take a look at
global supply chain management that just
kicks them up a whole other notch
because
taiwan punches above its weight
at an astronomical level in the global
supply chain
as a manufacturing partner especially in
semi
so if they take taiwan
they now just which they believe going
back to
chiang kai-shek and you know sending him
um you know
on the exile and all those things that
happened
this is a market share and a
uh legacy ownership so part of them
is hey this is legacy ownership this is
our land this is our
province this is our place i mean let's
let's uh
it's kind of like a west berlin thing
let's take down the wall this is ours
all the
all the way but the other side of it
they think the long game economically
this is a play for market share and
control over the west
of manufacturing listen all i will say
about this
all right they're on youtube right now
if you're listening to this all right
after this is done look up
my life my china i am a
communist party member just go into your
bar after this is over
and check chinese communist party member
and watch those videos and you tell me
if that
is the future that you want that's all
that's all i can say
all i can say everything tom said is is
great everything that we talk about here
is fine
guys you have to understand what is
going on on a global scale you have to
understand
who is pulling the strings who is
pulling the levers you have to
understand who
xi jinping is and what his goals are
all right and part of what we are
looking for in the future
if you don't understand what we talked
about on tuesday when we're talking
about a social score
if you don't understand all right and
you want an actual
human element that goes beyond the
politics and the economics and
the high level concepts that we talk
about here and you just want to
see for yourself what loss of anonymity
looks like what loss of
agency looks like search chinese
communist party member and watch those
videos
that's that's all i'll say
let's see what happened there you want
to get adam in here to promote his new
podcast if we can get adam adam come on
in here adam's been hiding back there
the entire time it's a great day to have
a good day folks
enjoy your weekend thank you
valuetainers yes appreciate you adam
tell us what is happening adam tell us
about your
camera sure of course but first i'll put
your mask on next time you come in here
adam where's your mask
where's your mask i left it in the car
pat how are we all doing
great show car hey i gotta tell you tom
the um
the david camp david accords with um
uh jimmy carter and uh that was good
stuff great reference
how are you feeling how are you feeling
man man i feel great i did my morning
workout
you know what i do it feels weird to be
on the right
cur you know curling clowns it's weird
to be here you're standing in slowly but
surely i've been going
i don't know if you uh if you hear what
he just said i heard it loud and clear
i heard it loud and clear slowly but
sure i started far left now i'm like
creeping onto the right side look at me
tell us about your podcast we got five
it's your workout this
morning standing front of the today show
curling your cats yes thank you in your
underwear
i'm sure kyle has an image so this
afternoon we're
launching uh something that i'm very
proud of called
the sauscast with your boy saz right
here so
um thank you very thank you happy to be
doing this so basically
um you know i started on this endeavor
i met pat in probably 2012 we were
working out in the gym i wasn't curling
cats at the time
almost nine years ago and uh we just
started up a conversation
tom let let me let me get in here um
and we just started talking and we were
in the same industry
insurance uh finance and they were just
two dudes
in uh in the gym working out at this
conference called nalba
and i had just started in the industry a
few years you had just started php a few
years
we were like the only 30-somethings in
this
what i call mp a male pale and stale
crowd no offense
and um it was just a boring industry and
i
and i'm i'm in something called life
settlements and i had a breakthrough
career in that industry made some money
you've obviously been crazy
uh successful in industry and i said oh
wow
this is how money works this is how
investments works this is how
life insurance works this is how premium
finance works this is how estate
planning works
they don't teach you this [ __ ] in school
and you know i was just like gerard over
there i was a stand-up comedian i was a
nightlife guy in miami i was a
substitute teacher i had a whole as sort
of a jack of all trades
and i got a job as a cold caller in the
financial world for my firm that i'm
still with
and it basically sort of peeled back the
curtain of how money works and how
finance works
and i started my show sas talks money in
probably 2016
when i had some built up some wealth and
and
you know had some extra time and uh it's
fast forward now i'm on valuetainment
couldn't be any happier and
i actually kind of approached this idea
to you
back in dallas and pat gave a buddy
buddy so you know slow down buddy you
know like
start doing some videos i said all right
cool i'll keep doing the videos keep
doing the videos
but ultimately i realized what my
biggest gift is is just being able to
really talk to anybody and relate with
anybody
i used to sleep on my buddy's couches
and
fast forward 10 years i had nba players
crashing on my couch
so wherever you're at in life i've been
there
and really the point of the size cast is
i can
talk to people like live interact and
just be myself not scripted
not uh you know cut edit whatever let's
go back
no b-roll just oh so you're stopping the
whole show you've been doing this entire
time so that's stopping with you and uh
the the scripted uh five minutes we'll
still do some of that but this is the
main
this is the main how long is this show
going to be it's going to be an hour
live podcast every thursday every
thursday 4 p.m after the bell
okay and we're going to have it's all
personal finance related
so this is thursday thursday 4 p.m
eastern standard time okay
and what should people expect of this
podcast people you should expect to get
smarter with money okay you're going to
learn
tips techniques to build wealth you're
going to figure out strategies how to
get out of debt
save that money or no 100 okay so you're
going to take in calling we're going to
take on calls we're going to have q and
a and we're going to do that today
today yes okay so today folks kai can we
put the link below
episode one today episode one biz doc
would you be a future guest on the show
we had a great time i would have to do
it our interview was great
you brought my favorite beer and
crackers yes i'll bring more beer and
crackers put the
put the link below for sauce
sauce cast at 4 p.m every thursday
eastern standard time with adam sosnick
and you can call in
uh link below go uh it's not even
subscribed to it because it's
valuetainment economics you've been
there yeah
channel the biz doc is doing his case
studies i love this idea i love this
idea it's like squawk on the street
after the bell but with attitude for
personal finance yes personal finance
and look is that a good summary thank
you i appreciate that there's going to
be
a lot of attainment going on too there's
going to be value i'm saying that's the
attitude but there's
we're going to have fun we're going to
talk about you know maybe that's a
banter the way
lots of banter the way i sort of look at
it is it's if like
if dave ramsey and howard stern had a
love child
and uh that would be oh
personal finance but but we're going to
have some fun i love it pat maybe
maybe you'd be a guest one of these days
we'll see like tables will turn
i actually think this is going to do
great i think people are going to be
able to call in
and see a different side of you and just
kind of talking to you about money how
you went from uh being a comedian in
denver colorado trying to figure out a
way whether you can do that you're broke
you don't have any money to do anything
to being a cash millionaire i think
people need to learn nowadays how to be
a cash millionaire
and you can definitely share with them
some tips on how to do so folks today
every thursday 4 p.m eastern standard
time
one hour sauce cast go click
what is that button you click to be
alerted when the live goes up kai what
is that the bell
the bell thank you david yeah the bell
today
thursday 4 p.m adam happy for you
looking forward to seeing that show
and i'd like to say one last thing tell
us i loved what you did with
uh your video with obama trump i know
we've been talking about that for a few
weeks
and uh respect i personally would like
to donate ten thousand dollars
to your cause to make that happen you're
being serious i'm being very serious
adam giving ten thousand dollars when
you
so we're officially at what five point
six million ten thousand dollars
i would love to put up five million or
what aaron singerman did a five hundred
thousand but
i'm gonna stay in my thousands ten
thousand yeah that's good good for you
for doing that
that's just a saturday night in south
beach i'm just gonna stay in on saturday
there it is bottle service at the vip
all right you heard it here adam's got
10k on it
and uh go make sure you do not miss
sauce cast
4 p.m eastern standard time with that
being said are we doing it again next
tuesday same time
yes sir sir it's the same way next
tuesday
9 a.m uh back here on the pbd podcast
but today
4 p.m with sauce cast on valuetainment
economics have a great weekend
good to see you glad bye bye